everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm and today we're continuing
our coverage of the 2018 st. louis rapid
and blitz tournaments the first three
days are all rapid they play three
rounds of rapid chess that means you
have 25 minutes on your clock 10 seconds
are added for every move that you make
the first two days we did see Fabien
Fabiano Cara wanna just dominate and
taking the lead into day three
unfortunately he faltered coming out the
gate in round 7 he had the white pieces
going against Dominguez and lost and
then he went on to draw the next two
rounds that opens up the door for other
competitors to actually come in and tie
Fabiana for the lead or actually go in
and win the rapid portion themselves one
of those players looking to get a share
of the victory and the rapid portion is
Nakamura we saw him lose in round one
since then he has been on eights here he
does face a tough Challenger in round 9
and that is Dominguez the same wild card
player that Fabiano lost to when Fabiana
had the white pieces in round seven so
we're gonna go and get into it starting
out with Nakamura the white pieces
starts out pawn to e4 pawn e5 Knight f3
knight c6 Bishop b5 it if you watch any
top-level play you pretty much know that
this is gonna be the Berlin defense and
that's exactly what we see Knight to f6
Castle on the kingside Knight takes on
e4 and then rook to e1 there's really
two options the white normally plays
here pawn to d4 or rook to e1 and
nakamora decides for rook to e1 now the
knight comes back to d6 and then that up
here a five attacking at the Knights
Bishop here e7 we see the bishop retreat
back to f1 after the Knight takes rook
captures here castle on the Kings side
and then Knight to c3 just development
move from white and this is where I
thought it was interesting as far as how
black continues here there's we see so
much Berlin defense you really get
accustomed to what moves players are
going to make but there's a few
situations where you're not really sure
how they're going to continue especially
in a rapid portion these guys are going
blazing
they're not really thinking more than a
second or two in their move so it's all
about preparation that's why you see a
lot of Berlin offense they just prepared
this so much but in this position where
does black go from here I was expecting
Bishop to f6 forcing the the rook to
move could always play pawn to b6
opening up for the LightSquared Bishop
come st. get it to b7 attack the light
squares in the center of the board but
we see something interesting and that's
Knight back to Yeates bringing the
material back to the ring not something
I expected to see Knight to d5 Nakamura
says yeah I'm gonna start pushing my
material here Bishop to d6 forcing the
Knights to come back or the rook to come
back to e1 pawn to c6 forcing the knight
to come back III Bishop e7 and that up
here f5 attacking the bishop Bishop g5
Queen to e2 setting up for the Knights
come to e7 since both the bishop and the
Queen are defending this square wants to
make sure he has extra defenders here
pawn down here to d5 and the knight to
deep re7 says yeah I want to go ahead
and take one of your bishops I'm gonna
have the bishop pair in this game and
that's exactly what happens we see the
King come to h8 since was under check
and the knight takes and then the rook
captures here on c8 pawn to b3 opening
up for the dark squared bishop to come
to beat sue Fink head o on the Queen
side at the board Knight to f6 just
development move for getting this knight
involved and wasn't doing much back here
on the 8th ranks wants to make sure it
is more involved into the action Bishop
to b2 as we expected Knight down here to
e4 it's nice little outpost not really
going to hold on to this for too long
very easy to just play pawn to d3 and
then Bishop up here to f6 and says yeah
if you want to exchange if you want to
come up here take with your Bishop I can
just recapture with my Knights right
here
why decides for another plan plays pawn
to c4 and says yeah I'm gonna thin my
Bishop with my Queen now I'm gonna push
in the process with my pawns Mike
decides to go ahead and take with his
Bishop down here on b2 I think he does
have another option not the easiest to
find
away and that is to play Knight to c3
attacking the Queen
you know if Nakamura wants to go ahead
and exchange as Bishop here Bishop comes
back here I think this is fun this gets
back to a spot where both sides are even
in material you don't have to worry
about your opponent having bishops and
you have a knight and then the board
opens up and they have more aggressive
pieces and if for some reason the Queen
moves Queen to d2 makes a lot of sense
then pawn to d4 is started getting
tricky for for white to deal with
removing this pawn right here you really
need a knight or the dark squared Bishop
doesn't really have those doesn't have
another pawn that can come and remove
this as well so this is gonna be a great
outpost for black here really just gonna
see nakamura exchanged materials so he
doesn't have to deal with that but in
the game we see Dominguez instead of
playing Knight to c3 which i think is
probably the better option he decides
just go ahead and take this Bishop here
on B tube and then queen takes on beats
you as well so white does have the
bishop
Black has knight needs to move the
knight comes back here to f6 so very
important that black maintains some
structure in the center of the board he
wants it to stay closed does not want to
open up this board state bishops are
gonna do much better if all the pawns
are off the board can control the entire
board state where if there's a lot of
pawns you're trying to move around
material Knights do better because they
can't be blocked off they can hop over
so that's really what blacks going
forward not come are on the other hand
looking to exchange all the pawns off
the board and really dominate with the
the only minor piece that can control
most the board and that is this light
square bishop here on f1 Nakamura starts
to attack on the Queen side place Queens
a3 attacking the pawn and this rook
appear on f8 main target though is the
pawn on a7 and what do you see black
play pawn down to e5 it is protected by
the Queen on d8 but I really don't like
to tie up material especially your most
powerful piece on the board to defending
upon I think it's just as easy to play
pawn to a6 this is going to be to find
it defended by the pawn now the Queen
can get involved don't have to worry
about it but decides to push a little
further play pawn to a5 rook up here to
e7
is a great move from Nakamura you always
want to get your rook on your opponent's
seventh rank and since he does have this
Queen here on a3 does add that
protection here that he could really
start to attack this rook is attacking
right now this pawn on b7 instead of
being as plays rook to b8 to protect
that rook over here to e1 and White has
all the attacking going on black is
really in defense mode
right now King to g8 just getting
another defender as close to the action
as possible pawn to g3 opening up
forward the LightSquared bishop to come
here to the g2 squared and really
control these light squares in the stern
of the board rook here to e8 and then we
started to see some exchange on the
board rook takes on e8 the knight takes
and then pawn takes Queen comes down
here to d5 naught and then Bishop to g2
as we talked about now forcing the Queen
to move Queen comes back here to d8 and
then Queen c5 so centralized in the
Queen
it is also attacking this pawn on e5
which it was before but just continues
to improve his position as well as force
his opponent to still defend this square
over here on a5 black looking to get is
not involved into the game plays Knight
to f6 and then Queen to a7 this almost
seemed like it what knock more have been
going for always putting pressure on the
pawn on a5 but always getting his pieces
in a more aggressive position the
seventh rank is exactly where you want
to be the queen is extremely dangerous
because the rook now threatens rook to
e7 black queen can't take this because
then the rook here on b8 is going to
fall so really tricky as far as how
black continues he recognizes that
there's some back rank made
opportunities for white in the future
so he plays pawn to g6 giving his own
King some air so he can come to g7 if a
number needs to in a pinch and then pawn
to d4 Queen down here to d6 trying to
centralize the Queen there's not a lot
of great squares for the Queen to come
to but says yeah I'll come down here I
can take this pawn if you were to take
my pawn on a5 so he still has the
material you know Equalization right
there there
see rook to d1 says okay I'm gonna
defend this pawn now I can attack your
pawn here on a5 Queen comes back here to
d8 protecting that pawn pawn up here to
h3 now this just negates even more
squares that black can go to can't bring
his knight here to g4 already couldn't
come to e4 so nakamora doing a good job
of cutting off all of the potential
options that black has blacks really
just sitting there playing defense right
now King to g7 rook here to e1 Knight
back to d7 the same thing knocking Wars
done all game any time black retreats
nakamura pushes for the night here on f6
was protecting the square on d5 it is no
longer so nakamura pushes forward with
pawn d5 we see an exchange in the center
of the board bishop takes and now white
has done what we talked about you need
to do and that is open up the board
state this night here on d7 is not
adding a lot of value not putting
pressure on white this light square
bishop controls the entire game right
now with an open board state it can get
to anywhere very very quickly but
already attacking two of these pawns
right here for black so blacks in a
world of trouble has to defend as best
as possible and just hope that Nakamura
makes a mistake
fortunately for black Nakamura does not
make him any mistakes especially in a
rapid format the knight comes back to f6
seems like the square it always ends up
bishop comes back to f3 Queen to a c7
King up here a g2 just protecting the
pawn on h3 pawn down h5 just pushing
forward here h4 Queen comes back here to
DA and this is an interesting spot
because Nakamura I think finds the best
move but it's very tempting just to go
ahead and take this material here on b7
it almost looks like your opponent
doesn't know what's going on it doesn't
feel like he has a great move and so
just gives up some material because what
else can he do here but from here black
can just come down play Queen to c7 this
is threatening to take material here he
does have both the rook and the Queen
it's hacking this b7 square so yeah
maybe the rook comes up here Queen takes
now the Queen takes the other
but then the Queen comes down here to a3
and black can gobble up material White's
not able to be up in material like he
was before so in this case why it's
probably not as good off as if he looks
at it and says yeah I can just take this
pawn but Nakamura finds the better move
and that is a rook up here to e5
continues the same threat that he had
before of taking on b7 but also opens up
the potential for taking material here
on a5 before it was always the Queen
attacking in the queen defending but now
the rook is involved just adding another
layer that black has to deal with from
the attacking fronts so Knight comes
down here to g7 or g4 excuse me
attacking the rook rook comes to d5 that
is being protected by the bishop on f3
attacking the Queen Queen comes down
here c7 but now Queen takes on a5 as we
talked about has protection from this
rook so that's one pawn pawn pushes
forward b6 forces the Queen - come back
here - D - now the Queen's eyeing over
on the Kings side the board Knight to f6
the same squared the Dominguez has
brought it to almost every time here
Queen - a d4 and this is pinning down
the knight so if we thought the knight
wasn't doing much before it is not gonna
be moving anywhere anytime soon pawn to
b5 completely not looking at what's
going on but where does black really go
he's just trying for something
recognizing he has no moves on the King
side of the board and now come over here
finds a great decoy move and that's
Bishop taking on h5 the knight can't
take it because it's being pinned down
by the Queen the pawn can't take it
because rook can come over here to g5
check forcing the King to move here it's
gonna come off this is the only defender
of the night here on f6 so as soon as it
moves then this nights gonna fall here
on f6 and White's just up too much
material can gobble up this pawn here on
h5 you know up three pawns can just
start gobbling up even more material and
also threaten a back rake mates here or
mates on the back rank with the rook
here on h8 just so many threats that
black has to deal with so doesn't go far
from here
after the pond comes down here to b5 we
see that the equipment move a bishop
takes on h5 rook to a8 says yeah I'm
gonna try to take some material here on
a - Bishop comes back to f3 rook takes
on a - but then rook up to d6 Queen e7
there's just too much threats coming on
and then after pawn to g4 Dominguez
recognizes that pawn to g5 is the next
move there's no way to stop that the
knight is going to fall and at the end
of that he is forced to resign so
nakamura with the win jumps into the
lead
jumping Fabiana Caruana who drew his
last two matches for Nakamura though he
ends up tying for first in the rapid
section were shocked here to mama da da
who also had a great day 3 as well so
they share the lead of the rapid portion
there's an overall winner as well after
the bullet section we have 18 rounds of
blitz
starting tomorrow so lots of room for
all these competitors to be the overall
champion of the tournament but Nakamura
congratulations to him for tying first
place in the rapid section coming out
the gate always getting a loss in the
first round is tough but to battle back
in a format that is extremely good at in
win is is very encouraging so hopefully
you guys enjoyed the rapid portion the
blitz portion gets even crazier as they
have less time just so many wild
variations going to be fun over the next
few days so thanks for watching and I'll
see you guys tomorrow